welcome to bafta film craft the sessions
it's a series of talks with BAFTA
nominees looking at the craft that goes
into the many films that have been
nominated in the first session today
we're going to be looking at the role of
sand and Craig and Thomas E in many ways
whiplashes is the roller coaster ride of
the entries in terms of the history
behind it yeah I initially got the call
from the assistant director he was a
friend of mine and I was excited to get
a new job you know he calls and says hey
got this thing for you it's a short
schedule not a lot of money first-time
director it's gonna be really
challenging as I create sign me up and
so they sent me a script and that's when
you know it became clear as day that I
had to say yes for the most part you
know his music was really another
character in this film and we really had
a you know sort of work at that and the
time that we had to get it to where it
needs because Damien's a train jazz
drummer he was really on top of anything
all the time if there's snare wasn't
quite right or the Tom wasn't quite
right he was really on top of us about
that auntie I'm curious with some the
actual machine Turing's machine that he
created the sounds that were created a
random Morton wanted so I'd already
before the phone stand really got into
going to Bletchley and talk talking to
these enthusiasts so they're very kind
of interested in the machines and I did
some temp recordings just to see what
they sounded like but I realized we'd
have to set up a recording like on an
official basis and Mike it with
perspective I did consider the
possibilities that we'd like it from
many perspectives so we tried contact
mics on the on the machine itself that
exists and then in a variety of
different boom mics of different
positions and so I ended up with a multi
track of what is the existing machine at
Bletchley and so that was as good as it
go but that performance of an actor did
you see it's really good you know it's
so precious the act you know picture
picture alone in my opinion doesn't have
a soul the soul is in the sound
you know that's that's it the the
current situation is noise is good and
in fact I think for our silence is like
to an artists is like the white in the
paint pot you know when we can use
silence effectively and storytelling for
sound it does make it more engaging for
the audience and I think playing lots of
music lots of sound effects opening a
movie with a lot of noise you it's
difficult to sort of get engaged I think
you have to take the audience and really
gently and starting with very little
nothing at all maybe one very small
specific sound and she makes the
audience pay attention if you then take
it beyond what they expected in other
words by changing the dynamics greatly
you have an effect over them because
they jump all this an effect